- My name is unusual, Kirsten,
you don't see it very often,
especially my age and younger.
And one day, I was
wandering around Seaworld
and I went through the food line,
and the girl working the cash
register was named Kirsten.
So I asked her how she got her name,
and she said that the house she grew up on
was called Kirsten Place,
and her parents just liked the name
so they named her after the street.
But what's really funny about the story is
my dad is the one who named that street.
He named two streets in Spring Valley,
Karen Lane after my sister
and Kirsten Place after me,
because he was a developer
and he got to name the
streets in that town.
- I was actually abroad in New Zealand
and I was talking to a stranger about how
I wanted to go to a
hiking trail further off,
and she gave me her car for the day.
Just because I wanted
to go to a hiking trail
that was far away.
She didn't even know if I could drive,
let alone who I was,
and just gave me her car.
So I definitely remember
her, she was incredibly kind.
- So once, many years ago
when I was a student in
Milwaukee, Wisconsin,
I was crossing a street near my apartment
in a not so great area,
and a man approached me and took my scarf
and squeezed it across my neck
in an effort to attack me.
And I was frightened, and I
fought him off and ran home.
I've never forgotten him.
- [Girl] What were the feelings
you were left with after that?
- A state of vulnerability that
I'd not experienced before.
- The one stranger I remember
was in a grocery store,
the one in front of me,
noticed that we didn't have
money to pay for our food,
so she paid for all of our food.
It was over 100 dollars.
And I didn't know her name or anything,
she just paid for
everything and walked away.
I've never seen her again,
but she stays in my head
and I thank God for her
because she did a lot, a lot,
when we needed her.
- I remember back in my
hometown in East Texas,
this stranger randomly ran up to me,
without saying a word,
and to this day I still
don't know his name,
ran up to me, handed me 20 dollars
and took off in the opposite direction.
(laughing)
Nobody came running up
to it, so I kept it.
- It was Fourth of July, 1999,
the Starbucks in Coronado,
sitting, enjoying some tea,
obviously kind of looking around
to see if there are any beautiful women.
In walks a beautiful woman,
with her parents, no less,
and I found a way to start
a conversation with her,
and nearly 20 years later,
we're still together.
- I met a stranger in an
airport who's a retired nurse
that had saved about 80
children from a plane crash
and that left an indelible episode.
She was a young nurse, a
lieutenant in the Air Force,
and she was evacuating
Amerasian children from Vietnam
at the fall of the capital,
and the plane crashed on takeoff
and she saved the children.
No matter how badly injured she was,
she put up with the pain
to rescue those who were dependent on her,
and that made a lot of difference for me.
- So I was on a cruise
and I was just sitting,
looking at the view,
I had lost my family, I
didn't know where they were,
so I was just trying to
watch the ocean and watch everything,
and I was at a very
confused point in my life,
not really knowing what
I wanted to do with it.
And this random lady just came up to me
with her bottle of wine
and a book in her hand,
and she just starts talking
to me about her life,
and she was telling me about how
she was a nurse in Spain
and she was doing public health
and teaching moms how to breastfeed
and take care of their babies.
And I didn't know her name,
she didn't tell me anything about her,
she was just very happy and relaxed
and she just walked away and
told me to have a nice day
and that was one time when I knew
that I wanted to do nursing,
so that was pretty cool.
- [Girl] So you're
studying nursing right now?
- Yep, that's what I'm
doing right now, yeah.
- That's crazy!
- Yeah, yeah, it's really cool.
- I was ice skating
and there was a little five year old girl,
she walked up to me and she goes,
"Can I just tell you something?
"You are the most beautiful
girl I've seen today."
And it literally made my entire month,
I'd never gotten a compliment like that
from someone so little,
and I didn't think it would matter,
I don't know, it just did.
- So many years ago
I was coming back from a
camping trip with my family,
and this was pretty late at night
so I was sleeping in the backseat
and my brother was there as well,
and for some reason which I
don't understand to this day,
the door opened at the back
and I actually flew out
while we were on the middle of the road,
going at probably 40 to 50 miles an hour.
So I landed at the road,
but at this time I'm still sleeping,
I'm just like, "What just happened?"
and my parents just drove ahead
because they didn't notice
until maybe five minutes later,
where my mom heard the door
making a "woosh" sound at the back,
and looked back and she's like,
"Oh my god, where's Anan?"
They went to the side
and stopped immediately,
and at this point they're not even sure
where I am, what happened,
but luckily enough, someone
who was driving up stopped
because they saw something
in the middle of the road
that resembled a person,
and they got out of the
car, helped me to the side,
and I'm completely lost
and crying at this point,
and they walked me back
while my parents walked back,
so they kind of met in the middle.
And yeah, I don't remember his face,
but for obvious reasons
that's someone who's
basically changed my life,
because I wouldn't be here,
per se, if they ran over me.
Yeah, my parents said thank
you to them in the newspaper
and stuff like that,
so some pretty cool and crazy stuff.
- So I had someone message me
on Instagram a long time ago,
and we kind of befriended each other.
And then maybe a year later
they randomly messaged me and asked me
if I wanted to go to the Bahamas.
And I was like, well,
that's kind of weird,
but it was for a competition
that he won for Tinder
to where we would go on our first date
to swim with sharks for
the Discovery Channel,
so I met a complete stranger in Florida
and we flew with a bunch of people
and went to the Bahamas
to swim with sharks,
and that was the first time I met him.
- I went to hike with my parents,
it was really hot outside and
we forgot our water bottles
and he was pretty, pretty, pretty old
and was sitting on a bench,
and I was pretty dehydrated.
And he was getting some
water out of the well
and putting it in his hands
and he gave it to me
in his hands to drink.
And I was so relieved
that I can get some water,
I didn't even speak his language,
he was Greek or something,
and he gave us all water,
it was really nice and I
remember it to this day.
- [Girl] So you all drank
water out of his hands?
- Yeah, we did.
- Actually a gentleman I
met about six months ago,
I guess you could say homeless,
or just not doing too well,
we just had a great conversation
for about half an hour, an hour.
It's honestly the most frequent memory
that I think about, every now and again.
- [Girl] Do you remember
what you guys talked about?
- Family mostly.
He told me about his kids
and how he missed them,
and how he wished he
could do more for 'em,
and I was telling him about
how I wished I had a
family like that one day,
and being able to raise my
kids in a healthy home, really.
Just, even given where he
was, he seemed as inspiring
as many of the people that I know today
who are doing much better
in life than even I am,
to be honest,
and he saw life in a way
that people don't truly
understand it anymore,
which is, everyone is equal.
- I remember a woman coming up to me,
asking me how to use Facebook,
but she didn't have her phone
so I couldn't really help her,
so she gave me a dollar
anyway and just walked away.
I don't know, it made me happy,
that things like that just sort of happen,
sort of like this right now.
- The stranger,
I remember I was about
four or five years old
and a guy broke into my house,
he came through my window
and he tried to duck me,
and then the neighborhood all
jumped on him and tackled him
and then the cops came and arrested him.
So that's a stranger that I remember.
As the story goes I was asleep
during most of the incident.
- I was in Madrid airport,
I'd been visiting my brother
who was living there,
and me and my friend were in the queue
and there was this lady in
front of us, maybe 60 something,
and she just turned round
and she started to talk to us
about the power of the universe,
and "The Secret", which
is actually the first time
I'd ever heard of that book.
She was really bizarre, 'cause
she kind of just appeared,
dropped all this wisdom,
me and my friends all sat
there and didn't say anything,
and then she left,
and we actually never saw her again.
And it was really bizarre,
because we were both questioning
whether it was even real,
if she was ever there,
but it had a very profound
effect on both of us.
- We were camping, and
hiking and whatever,
we had seen this lady
hiking the trail by herself,
who was maybe in her fifties.
I thought it was cool,
I thought if I was single in my fifties,
I'd still go out and do this cool stuff.
And it was weird because
when we were camping
she actually had the camp spot next to us,
and came over and asked to share our fire,
so she wouldn't have to
make her own, or whatever.
I thought it was cool
because, I don't know,
I have a big family
and I've never done
anything by myself before,
and so I was like,
I'm gonna do that, I can do that,
I could go hiking,
I could invite myself
to stranger's campfires
or something like that, you know?
- I went to church once, and this lady,
I was probably ten years
old, sat right next to me.
Never knew her, never met her,
obviously she's a stranger,
and she give me a dollar
to give into the basket
and she just told me that
she will pray for me for
the rest of her life.
And that just stuck to me
because I didn't know her,
and I told her, I'll pray for you as well,
and I didn't believe in
religion in the moment,
I still don't but I was like,
God, if you are real,
take care of this woman.
- I met her at a camp,
and we were doing this
exercise of vulnerability,
and being able to make eye contact
with somebody you don't know.
We were in this group of 50 people,
her and I were moving in the circle,
moving from person to person,
and when her and I met eyes,
we both just started crying.
At that time I didn't have
a good relationship with my mother,
so when I saw her
I felt like I saw an
older version of my mom,
and that time I really desired to have
a better connection, better
relationship with my own mother,
that's just something that
was going on in my deep self.
- The stranger was here at the park,
and he was an older
gentleman that we stopped,
actually right over here,
to take a picture of us,
believe it or not.
And he did a fantastic job,
he just stopped and asked
all the right questions,
he was a little eccentric,
to say the least,
but he did a great job
taking the pictures,
when I was walking by right now,
I just happened to remember him,
you happened to ask that
question, so it's interesting.
- I was actually looking for
a rock shop close to our area,
and I found this guy that has
a rock shop in his basement.
He took me on a hunting trip for flint,
and then two hour, actually four hour trip
we found out we were probably
brothers of another mother.
We became instant best friends,
so it kind of seems like
I've never met a stranger
that I didn't like,
and somehow become best friends.
(gentle music)